right here with reaction Senate
Judiciary Chairman Lindsey Graham is
with a senator I was I'm a little
concerned about to your fellow
colleagues one John Cornyn of Texas and
the other Mitch McConnell your leader
Cornyn saying oh we've got to have whoo
there's not 51 votes to dismiss this
sham process and then McConnell kind of
seemingly backing him up and I'm like
wait a minute
if there's no due process that was like
was afforded Bill Clinton his attorneys
the Democrats they're gonna take this up
anyway in the Senate well here's the
trials in the Senate right if they get
it right okay let's say they let's say
they get 218 votes here's what I
promised the country we're not going to
try the president United States based on
hearsay so any resolution setting up a
trial in the Senate I'm going to make
sure that hearsay cannot be the basis of
an impeachment allegation if you invoke
the hearsay rule what would be left that
I mean it's a great question I was
surprised is especially considering you
it said it was DOA without the
whistleblower without due process we
have none of that can I can I build this
in a trial in the Senate to me knees
should not legitimize what's going on in
the house
no American is denied the right to call
witnesses on their behalf except Donald
Trump no American is accused of
wrongdoing anonymous anonymously except
Donald Trump what they're doing in the
house is a danger to the presidency
itself so any trial in the Senate needs
to make sure that you can impeach a
president based on hearsay because
that's a danger to the presidency itself
and secondly any trial in the Senate
must exposed a whistleblower so the
president can confront his accuser I
will not accept a trial in the Senate
until I know who the whistleblower is so
you know a lot of the hearsay hearsay
hearsay hearsay you know for we hearsay
5 we hearsay you know went back to the
testimony in private as they were
auditioning and cherry-picking their
witness
but they keep referring to the
ambassador Sunland has said the
president clearly stated I want no quid
pro quo we know Volcker testified that
he didn't receive any indication of any
quid pro quo president Solinsky there
was zero pressure III you know three
meetings with these guys and the
president of Ukraine president Solinsky
he never did anything and he still got
the aid I'm like so where is the issue
quit and the Pro and the quo help me out
well you know they got the money and
nobody investigated Joe Biden in the
Ukrainian government so there's no there
there but let's go back to the idea of
how you would what kind of trial would
you conduct if you excluded hearsay like
every other court in the land there's
nothing there
and if you allowed the President to
confront their acute his accuser you
would have to call the whistleblower and
here's the question I have about the
whistleblower was the whistleblower
connected to Joe Biden in any way did
the whistleblower get himself or herself
and he did well we tears the point I'm
trying to make let let me let here's the
point did the whistleblower engage in an
effort to get the ukrainian President
poroshenko to weigh in and stop the
investigation of this gas company was
there a connection between the
whistleblower and buy-ins
Biden's effort to call the Ukraine now
that's very important to me and we
cannot legitimize an impeachment based
on an anonymous source if you do that no
president will be allowed to survive
into my fellow members of Congress how
would you like to be in the shoes of
Donald Trump you're accused of something
based on a whistleblower who's anonymous
and you can't call witnesses on your
behalf now I have found evidence of a
quid pro quo
quid pro quo Joe because he says to
Ukraine in a shakedown you're not
getting the billion dollars unless you
fire that prosecutor fire the prosecutor
you get the billion don't fire the
prosecutor you
get the billion who's the prosecutor
prosecutors the guy that he was told as
investigating his son zero experience
hunter who's being paid millions of
millions of dollars now that seems like
a quid and a pro at a quote we actually
found one I
why is there zero interest for these
people that claim this is so bad quid
pro quos are bad that claimed election
interference is bad we have evidence of
both here except not on their side this
is an honor this is not about getting to
the truth it's about destroying the
president knighted States Adam Schiff is
not an independent person here Muller
and everybody else involved in
impeachment in the past were outside of
politics here's my point did the
president of the Ukraine poroshenko the
previous president did he receive a call
from Joe Biden and was that call related
to the investigation of the gas company
that hunter Biden was sitting on so I'm
gonna write it nobody else will a letter
to the former person of the Ukraine did
you ever get a call from Joe Biden
calling off the dogs regarding this gas
company well the Senate call the
compromised congenital liar shift will
they call members of his staff about the
contact with the whistleblower will the
whistleblower be forced to testify in
the Senate and what about fire and Joe
Biden we'll all of that happened great
question as a matter of oversight I'm
not going to call a House member but if
you impeach the president of the United
States I want to find out if in fact
Schiff and his staff met with a
whistleblower what he said today is it
true so if there's a trial in the Senate
where the witnesses will be Adam Schiff
because if he in fact did meet with a
whistleblower and coach the guy up I
think that's relevant to the impeachment
inquiry itself all right senator thank
you for being with us we appreciate your
hard work on all of this